hey Siri turn on the lights
[Music]
[Applause]
very nice Siri very nice let's turn up
the energy this time and take it from
the top welcome Syria and home pod
you'll be going through three rounds of
tryouts today during each I may call on
your competitors to show you how I like
things done hi there hi understood Siri
I'm sorry your language is somewhat new
to me great since your maker is most
focused on music we will begin with that
hey Siri volume up to 100 and play shape
of you by ed sheeran okay let's hear
shape of you by ed sheeran sounds really
good even from here hey Google hi what
can I do for you play shape of you at
max volume shape of you by ed sheeran
sure playing on Spotify okay too loud
too loud and a little distorted shape
you by Ed Sheeran from Spotify Alexa
don't even try please I knew I should
have invited the $200 Sonos one ok Siri
you clearly win here but can you beat
this hey Anna please play moonlight
sonata by Beethoven
and a what would $350 get me six more
minutes hey Siri play Michael Jackson's
beat it on Spotify I can't play from
Spotify did you know that Spotify has 70
million subscribers I can't get the
answer to that own home pod I'm back
here now we're gonna be testing
microphone range hey Siri mm-hmm good
you can hear me round to general
knowledge and assistance hey Siri do I
need an umbrella tomorrow
we'll see some rain tomorrow but it will
clear up later hey Siri how old is Chuck
Norris Chuck Norris is 77 hey Siri
what's my next appointment I can't get
the answer to that on home pod hey
Google your next meeting is called very
important lunch and is on Tuesday at
noon hey Siri call mom I can't help you
make calls on home pod hey Siri get me
an uber I can't help with rides here
Alexa there is a new Brett's two minutes
away from your Alexa address nicely done
Alexa
okay Siri final round home chores for
this we're going to need some props hey
Siri turn on the light okay hey Siri
changed the color to blue uh-huh hey
Siri changed the color to green here
goes hey Siri turn on the fan hey Siri
make me tea
not bad not bad at all Siri and this was
all fairly easy to set up using home kit
except the home app can be very
confusing and Alexa and Google work with
far more smart home devices and that's a
wrap
good news home pod you make it to the
smart speaker finals it's nice to be
appreciated you still need to work on
some of those tasks Siri but you do
produce some beautiful music for three
hundred and fifty dollars scaramouche
scaramouche will you do the fandango Leo
Galileo Galileo Galileo Galileo Figaro
Magnifico